[Musik]
was ist das
wenn ich im Weltall gelandet
hallo
[Gelächter]
dafür kann ich nicht
explodiert und mir noch meine Scheiben
kaputt macht dann Bruder komm zu meine
Nummer für immer löschen
die machen keinen Schaden wenn sie
Wasser sind oh mein Gott Leute was ist
das denn was ist denn wir haben Zombie
auf dem Huhn ich komme raus
oh nein nein nein
überhaupt nichts
warum ist dann warum ist das warum
ich habe gar nichts gemacht es kann ja
nicht sein dass wieder bei mir genauso
was passiert und bei dir nichts ja ich
wohne ja schon in einem Baum da kann ich
noch ein Baum wachsen
und ich finde das total schön dass ich
jetzt auch ein Chat habe dass sie mir
alles schreiben war luca war Luca töte
Luca mist ich suche jetzt erstmal mein
Pferd weil irgendwie schreiben wir alle
vergeht zu deinem Pferden an alle die
sich mitbekommen haben am Ende vom
letzten Streamer Weg war habe ich hier
fertig hier den Namen gegeben dadurch
dreht sich das nämlich um mal schauen
wann sie es merkt warum ist mein Pferd
warum ist das auf dem Boden
[Musik]
meine Döner
was ist hey kannst du noch reiten ja
aber
[Musik]
was war das denn Digger
Pranke ich hoffe der hat mich noch mal
kurz Mikro aus hey ich hoffe wenn ich
ähm
wie soll ich denn Luca mal Pranken dem
fällt alles auf
Luca das war natürlich nur ein prank äh
dass ich die Pranken wollte das war der
prank ja das war der prank
Leute Luca ich muss jetzt auf Klo bis
gleich Leute okay ich brauche eine Idee
was machen wir was machen wir ganz ganz
ganz schnell ganz schnell ganz schnell
ganz ganz ganz ganz ganz schnell
[Musik]
prankbros level
nicht checken geguckt nie hoch hat er
auf dem Baum nicht gesehen was ich auch
gerade gelesen habe war Spinnennetz auf
ihr Bett setzen dass sie das Putzen muss
[Musik]
einfach länger nicht an diesen Orten
wodurch das alles ein bisschen verstaubt
ist
was
zu Hause was ist da denn ich kann noch
einmal Spinnennetze überall die kann gar
nicht schlafen gehen schon wieder ja
okay wie lange warst du nicht mehr hier
du hast ja die ganze Zeit da hinten an
deiner Dings gearbeitet an einer
pferdedings oder
so schnell verstaut sondern das
verstaubt du musst es einfach abbauen
ja egal ich gehe jetzt erstmal schlafen
und den Rest kümmer ich mich später
Laser nein ich bau dich für dich ab
nicht dass du wieder denkst dass ich das
hier irgendwie war mein Pferd da oben
bei mir ist das unten ist ein Fehler bei
dir bei mir ist das unten bei dir drin
hier komm ich zeig's dir
bei mir steht dein Pferd hier genau hier
nein das ist doch hier oben hier
also bei mir steht es genau hier warte
ich schau mal deinen stream
[Applaus]
[Musik]
okay
keine Ahnung Luca wenn du mich stell
Dich jetzt mal davor stellen ja wo denn
wohl zum Pferd stellen hier
bei dir
[Musik]
du alter du alter verarscher
nein jetzt bei mir auch oben
richtig attraktive Frau Luca
[Musik]
was ist da passiert bei dir neben dir
explodiert
gib dir sofort die Sache das hat so
lange gedauert diese Laterne zu bauen
ich reicht komplett aus warum sind
Birkenholz in der Steinkiste das war ich
jetzt wirklich nicht das war jetzt
wirklich nicht sieht das geil aus ihr
hattet recht ihr hattet recht er hatte
recht
guck mal
wie findest du es Laser
da oben sehe ich noch eine haftstufen
halben Stein sehe ich da wie kann denn
deine Kuh sein
danke
verstecken in Minecraft das haben Luca
ich tatsächlich schon gespielt
ich habe Luca nicht gefunden leider
ja ich war unter der Erde aber du kannst
ja normal verstecken wenn Du möchtest
alles klar
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich dachte das wäre eine Art sich nicht
zu verstecken das einfach vom Server
gehst
eine Frage nervt es euch wenn ich
schreie das wird mich echt auch mal
interessieren nein nein passt schon Nein
langsam schon gewöhnt alle die es nervt
diesen eh nicht mehr dabei weißt du
Post kannst ja Podcast ja auch nicht
anders gewöhnt das stimmt luca du darfst
in fünf Minuten wieder hochkommen zu mir
kommen okay alles klar
dann wirklich Luca schnall dich schon
mal vor deinem Stuhl an du wirst in
Ohnmacht fallen wie geil das aussieht
glaub es mir
bin gespannt
[Musik]
kennt glaub es mir nur wenige Minuten
später
[Musik]
und die Glocker ist auch hier gegangen
will auch mal den Eingang begutachten
komm mal rein raus
warte mal ganz kurz hier das hier noch
schließen ach so scheiße wie schließe
ich das denn
guck mal wie hübsch sieht das denn bitte
von außen aus Laser
ja schön
also dafür dass das hier das Minecraft
so gefühlt seit zwei Wochen spielst ist
das sehr sehr gut geworden ja danke
alles Gute also Leute ähm danke euch für
den Support es waren relativ was als
kurzer Stream drei Stunden waren wir
live aber ich muss noch was kochen in 20
Minuten Champions League los
[Musik]